good morning Arcadia hoax  well they really put this one up fast we  need to design form set no one will ever  pay attention to I have chosen three  forms that people on the mud planet tend  to ignore a girl a Latino what is a  Latino you command of X will be  reconfigured as a senior citizen  [Music]  prepare to be destroyed enemy forces led  a coup and we were forced to flee for  our life destroy leader will be  perfectly safe here so long as we keep a  low profile  why aren't they looking at this the  coolest bravest spot Kiki's teenager  [Music]  Prince crown I have a question raise  your hand back home I have four of them  they are under the protection of vatos  vixx who else can hide is beyond my  reach assemble  don't you know protestors on fire I'm a  quick study together you are unstoppable  is this some new attack  you